tu as pris ton temps moteur
[Musique]
lui enseignez vous c'est un génie le jeu
pourrait lui enseignez vous demeurez à
londres j'aimerais tourner à varsovie
avec ma femme et mes filles je vais le
laisser ici
je dois g piano un peu je suis en génie
je vais t'apprendre tu deviendras un peu
gêné
ont fait bonne équipe non
voici un nicolau galliano fillion 1735
joyeuse bar mitzvah damidot
encore
c'est ça qu'ils ont vécu mes soeurs et
parents
[Musique]
tu sais combien de gens son mari elle
soit le moteur des dizaines de milliers
et perso c'est comment il s'appelait
[Musique]
je dis peut-être trouvé ça va devenir de
nouveau passe-temps martin vous
retrouver david qu'ils insultent encore
une fois je cherche d'avis drapeau porte
[Musique]
llano 2735 vous cherchez un instrument
aux propriétaires les deux
buts quand la dernière fois c'était il
ya longtemps c'est un virtuose mais il a
envie roma je n'avais jamais rien
entendu de tel pourquoi ce que tu
continues à le chercher tu perds ton
temps notre temps il ne peut être plus
que moi
[Musique]
pourquoi ne fausse pas sûr que tu
comprendrais
[Musique]